the pleasure to be here thank you for
inviting me and I like most
to talk about the stuff that my lab is
doing and so what I'm going to
concentrate on today is the use of AR to
assist in skilled task performance so in
order to be able to talk about AR I want
to make sure we're on the same page so
I'm going to give you a definition of AR
by starting with the definition of VR so
the way I like to think of VR is as a
computer-generated world of virtual
media of various sorts 3d so there are
things that you perceive especially with
your two eyes and their two ears and
your entire body interactive in which
all those things are tracked relative to
the user so we know where they are
relative to us now one thing I've tried
to be very careful with over here is to
make a definition that is agnostic as to
the particular kind of medium so you'll
see here a lot of people define VR in
terms of visual stuff
and while most of what I'm going to talk
about is indeed going to be visual I
wanted to at least be non visually
chauvinistic when I introduce the topic
so what is AR AR is basically all of the
above and then some and the then some is
that the virtual stuff is registered in
3d aligned in 3d geometrically and as
well also photo metrically with the
perceptible real world so again I've
tried to maintain that lack of visual
chauvinism over here even though most of
what I've shown you folks so far and
most of what I'm going to talk about are
things that really appeal predominantly
to your eyes maybe secondarily to your
ears and in a distant third to your
sense of touch tactics in general and
then of course ultimately but not right
now also to your sense of smell and
taste and all that other kind of really
good stuff that people don't do quite as
well as they do the other media so in my
lab a lot of what we concentrate on is
user interfaces for advented reality so
we've worked in navigation building a
big monster backpack based system back
in the mid 90s so we could walk around
and see information about things outside
you like like everybody else we love
names and entertainment this is an
example of a marble maze in which you're
manipulating a patterned piece of board
and the system is adding the virtual
stuff sounds and the sight of the
virtual things that move around as you
tilt and move the board and then task
assistance which is what I'm going to be
concentrating on which is using AR to
help people perform tasks explaining to
them where things are which things need
to get done how they need to get done so
that we can have people perform tasks in
a way that's more efficient that's more
effective than when they are presented
with information in some other way so
that said what I want to do is basically
talk about a set of different things
that we've done in my lab and I'm going
to start with talking about remote task
assistance this is a very classical
paradigm in which in many many fields we
have the notion of a remote person and
I'm going to be talking about that
remote person using the
industry-standard
acronym Smee which stands for a subject
matter expert there's someone who knows
something they're expert in something
and usually it's great to have an expert
when you're not an expert and with the
idea is we want to have that room
subject matter expert be remote from a
person who is sort of the boots on the
ground who actually is doing some tasks
and we'd like to be assisted by that
subject matter expert and so one thing
we're particularly interested in is how
do we do this not just for tasks like
maintenance and repair and assembly
which this sketch kind of speaks to but
I'd like to be able to do it in a way in
which that remote person doesn't need to
have for example a copy of the
environment a physical copy of the
environment in which the person really
physically is located who's going to be
doing the task I'd like to have that
remote person be able to have a need to
have as little as possible in terms of
the stuff the physical stuff that is
involved in doing the task part of the
reason I want to do that is we're
thinking in terms of who is this
designed for you think about a company
which someone
joins the company and they learn how to
and maybe even work on developing some
particular technology years past decades
past they're getting better and better
and better they're basically the go-to
person for perhaps a whole bunch of
different pieces of equipment and then
as they get more and more expert and
there may be less interested in
traveling the way they might have been
willing to or basically told to when
they were younger there comes a time in
which they want to retire and there's no
amount of money that's going to make
them decide to come in you know every
day eight o'clock and nine o'clock in
the morning and do the work they've been
doing they want to play with their
grandkids and do other fun stuff like
that and so what I'd like to do is to
imagine a world in which you can say to
someone who's getting ready to walk out
the door basically hey what if you were
willing to maybe one day a week just
tell us a little bit of advance notice
it could be even a day or two in advance
work from home right and be able to go
and get together with your old friends
who are still working for the company
and that's important because a lot of
people in the retiree they think they're
going to go out and play golf and have a
lot of fun but I've watched people do
this and maybe they don't get as much
reward from the things that they thought
they wanted to do all the time when they
were doing it all the time and they miss
the people they work with they just
don't want to do it 9:00 to 5:00 every
day ok so what if you can do it at home
and then you could say well you're going
to use some technology it's going to be
a head worn display and oh you don't
have one we'll buy you one your kids can
use it when you're not using it you know
there's a certain point at which it
becomes I hope a real you can't say no
kind of deal it's an offer that you
can't refuse if you make it appealing
enough and part of the appeal is going
to be not having a lot of physical
infrastructure like pieces of engines
and motors and other stuff like that
lying around the house which is really
what you don't want to have so how can
we allow this remote subject matter
expert to assist a local technician so I
see basically two kinds of tasks that
we've been trying to address for this to
me one of them is to help what I'll call
the technician radiation for that local
person boots on the
ground we want to get them to the right
place we want to get them to the place
where they're going to be performing the
tasks the right locations the right
position the right orientation there are
many tests in which you have to be in a
particular place you might not know
where that is and once you get there we
want to help you perform the task so
think of this as the where and the how
so let me give you some examples of some
of the things we've tried to do in terms
of getting in place but I'm going to do
is to show you a couple of stills and
then a little brief video of some of the
work we've done in which what you're
seeing over here is probably a little
hard to parse what's happening here is
this is a scale model and that's the
full hand actually I attract hand
pointing at within this scale model of
an aircraft engine so the aircraft
engine is much bigger we actually have
when sitting in the corner of our lab
this is a rolls-royce dart 510 turboprop
engine and these little guys over here
represent positions and orientations
from which you would need to go as the
local person to view this engine or the
right parts of the engine and this
little abstract thing here a little
sphere with a little pyramid sticking
out of it is actually a representation
of the tracked head of the local person
so this would move around as seen by the
remotes me and so here we have this
little model of the engine virtual model
it is tracked there's a little lazy
susan that you can see down here you'll
see this moving in a few seconds and you
can then spin it around and point to it
from the standpoint of this mate to
point to one of these good locations to
go to so when you point to that what
you're going to see in the video is this
is actually the real engine itself this
thing that looks kind of like a splayed
picture frame window is going to appear
in the environment and it's going to be
a cue for the technician to walk over to
it and look through it where they're now
going to begin the right position in
orientation and our Smee is going to
show them what to do all the while with
voice communications because that's
that's the easy stuff don't you don't
tell that to the people at Skype and you
all know how bad that can be what it
doesn't work well but there's a lot of
people working on making that stuff
work really really well so we have a
pretty good handle so let me show you
what this looks like here we have our
remote expert scene from a third party
view now we're going to see a view of
what he's seeing this is so-called video
see-through er he's spinning around that
lazy susan and now you can see his
finger on the right over there and he is
going to point to one of these guys and
that's going to show our technician what
to do so now our technician is wearing a
video see-through display is going to
walk over to look through it and the way
they knew to do that is this is what
they see this is one eye from a video
see through stereo display it's going to
look through there and now you're going
to see the hand of the or a
representation of the hand of the remote
expert pointing with this extended kind
of arrow sticking off of their finger
and they're going to pointed something
and they're talking with the person and
they're going to be able to go and give
them some advice so this is something we
did a couple of years ago and one
interesting thing about this is the way
people responded to this picture frame
window and so we want you to look
through it that's your instructions and
it turns out that different people do
different things when they encounter
that picture frame window there's some
folks who just go right up to it and
they like practically stick their head
through it and they're looking and at
something right now there's a certain
amount of slop there we were trying not
to say you have to be exactly here
looking exactly in this direction
because there are very few tasks like
bore sighting for example in which you
really have to be that constrained but
the result was we had some people who
did that looking right through the
window with other people who spend a lot
of time in museums they know if you get
that close to a painting a guards gonna
get very angry and so if it's sitting
over there they kind of step back a
little bit and they keep a respectful
distance and they're much further back
than we'd like them to be we didn't want
to go and try to verbally explain what
it is we wanted you to do so we're
looking at just general this idea of how
do I get you to a place that actually is
a range of possible positions and a
range of possible orientations so what
we ended up with is this work creating
what we call a para frustum and
basically is a generalization of the
your view volume or frustum that we have
in computer graphics in which it's a
truncated pyramid there's a single
center of projection there's a
particular direction in which you look
and the idea is that that would be one
way to tell you where we want you to be
but it's going to be very precise exact
position exact orientation and again for
many tests we don't want that so what
you're seeing here is a visualization of
this mathematical thing basically there
is a big ellipsoid over here it's size
its orientation its shape basically
would be determined per task and it is
essentially a target for the head we
need to get our head inside and here I
have one of my lab members wearing a
video see-through display but if he were
standing where this image were taken
from this is what he would see obviously
- himself sitting there in the
environment and it's a target get your
head inside of it which people tend to
do quite nicely the smaller it is
obviously the heart of the task is going
to be so now your head is inside we want
you to look in the right direction and
we have what we call the tail volumes
this is our head volume this is our tail
volume it's also an ellipsoid and also
depending on the task would change in
size position orientation both absolute
and relative to the head volume over
here and I'll take in a couple of
seconds how we use the tail volume to
constrain your orientation and then we
wrap the whole thing basically in the
big convex hull and you're seeing in the
parts that aren't actually part of these
ellipsoids you're seeing these little
ribs that go around the outside that
make it a little bit more visible and
that has a purpose that you'll see in a
couple of seconds so this is basically a
way that we have of representing this
range of very very large generous
targets - very very tiny targets for the
head that are going to be very very
difficult perhaps to precisely get
ourselves into so what I'm going to show
you is a little video of what this thing
in action since the video is going to go
by very quickly I want to just show you
a couple of stills from a
a slightly different video but it's a
video of the same general notion this is
our para frustum this one has a
relatively small head volume and a much
bigger tale volume and so this is our
view from one eye of our local
technician here they are getting closer
trying to get their head inside so they
can see that volume being projected
bigger here they've gotten their head
inside they can see this tail volume
which is very faintly outlined in red it
might be very hard for you to see right
now with the lights on and in fact they
want to have it be entirely within their
field of view okay if it's possible to
do there so this is an example of that
happening their head needs to be inside
here and if their head is inside here
inside that head volume and they see the
entirety of the tail volume then within
a matter of a second or so you're going
to see the ribs go away and that's the
sign that everything is okay but because
the head volume isn't physically
constraining it's all virtual you could
stick your head all the way through the
other end now it's behind you and then
to let you know that we start making and
it's happening over here that tail
volume starts blowing the very angry red
the closer you get to it the better it
gets and we also want it to be fully
inside and if it ends up cutting just
the top and not the bottom or just the
right side but not the left side then
you'll see these little white things
around the outside and indicate you
don't want that you want it to be inside
in fact we have a heuristic that says we
want to have that tail volume either
fully inside your frustum or outside on
both the left and the right or outside
on both the top and bottom can't be
outside of only one side and be capable
of being pulled in so that it isn't
outside on both of a pair besides it's
just a heuristic for wanting to be able
to see as much of it as possible and
here we have the person having pulled
back having centered it better and you
may or may not be able to see this very
thin red outline which is basically
outlining where the tail volume is and
now we have a range of motion that we
can have that will be okay so let me
actually show you this tree this in
action
so we're looking through one eye of our
video see through display and we're
putting our head inside of this as soon
as that yellow goes away we are now
inside and now for the interests of the
video we're going to go to far this is
really bad really we're very insistent
we pushing all the way and now we're
showing you when we're cutting on the
top bottom left right etc just on one
side you get that little white thing I'm
going to pull back now we're okay and
now we have this range based on the size
of the head and tail volumes of all we
can see and then we call out again over
there so this is an example this is a
particular visualization of this kind of
mathematical definition of what we call
a para frustum so what we do is we
design stuff like this and then we
actually do studies to see whether it
works well comparing it with other
things both that we've done and other
people do what I'm going to do and I
talked about the studies is these are
all things in which we do pilot studies
and we come up with hypotheses and then
we test the hypotheses and we watch out
for type 1 errors and we do all the
classical kinds of things if I spent my
time going into all that stuff and going
through all the hypotheses I wouldn't
have enough time to talk about the rest
of the stuff so I'm going to cherry-pick
just a little bit without explicitly
stating the particular policies that we
were looking at so use your study for
this thing
we compared basically this what we call
in-situ visualization or we just showed
you with another kind of visualization
this one is designed to be kind of like
a hut in a game for example a heads-up
display it's got these three dials over
here this one basically is telling you
are you looking in terms of yaw in the
right direction this one is basically
pitch are we looking up and down the
right amount and this guy at the top is
position and this means that no you need
to be a little bit further down over
here and then pitch correctly so this is
designed to live literally in the space
of your head worn display it's not
actually positioned out there at a
particular known place in the world and
let me give you an idea of what we
studied this is a collection of nine
different power
they are arranged in this little diagram
over here in terms of how tight the
position is so bigger ones looser
position constraints an easier target to
hit classic fits law but with your head
in 3d tighter and tighter as they get
smaller and smaller obviously you can
make it so small for us both eyes need
to be inside you could make it so small
that you couldn't do it and clearly you
would not want to have one that was
impossible let alone you wouldn't want
to have one that possible or not was
more constraining than you needed for a
particular task this is orientation this
is a little trickier for orientation it
turns out that a camel volume now we're
looking just at the tail volumes over
here and you're seeing a little tiny one
over there probably very hard to see
it's just a faint red outline and
there's a bigger one over there okay how
does bigger mean tighter if you have a
little teeny tiny one our rule says it
simply has to be in your field of view
and if it's literally like a point it
can be anywhere within that rectangular
cross-section field of view you have a
lot of constraint okay or rather a lot
of leeway as it gets bigger and bigger
from that little tiny one ultimately you
can make it the size that if you move
your if you're orient your head just a
tiny bit this way that way up or down
it's going to cut on only one side okay
and that makes it very very tight now
once it gets to be the tightest which is
the exact size of the cross-section of
the frustum if it gets bigger now gets
looser again okay so a really big one
well you can't get it entirely inside it
simply has to cut on both the left and
right or both the top and bottom okay so
that's a little do you look at this
carefully that might be a little
confusing so we basically came up with
nine different combinations of loose and
not so loose and fairly tight for the
position constraint in the orientation
constraint we did a study this case
weighed 18 participants this is within
subject experiments so people get
encounter balanced order the different
visualizations and for each one of our
participants they got to see the two
kinds of visualizations that I mentioned
to you there were six targets six places
where this para frustum could be
relative to in our case this aircraft
engine and there were at those different
places on nine different combinations
that I just showed you of head and tail
positions and orientations and sizes so
there were a hundred and eight not fifty
two times fifty four times two one
hundred and eight different combinations
that were given to each one of our
participants and so the take-home lesson
over here looking at these charts is
that this guy especially okay this is a
tight orientation constraint that when
you get that really tight orientation
constraint things take longer okay this
is hardly surprising it's basically fits
law little teeny tiny targets
hard-to-reach targets are going to be
ones that are going to take longer than
larger targets and so basically if you
think about it a tight position tight
orientation curve frustum is approaching
and in the extreme in a limit is
literally just a specification of a
frustum I need to be exactly here I need
to be looking at exactly in this
direction and that indeed as you might
imagine can take a long time to satisfy
than something which has much much
looser constraints by the way we did
this in stereo and so for us we were
talking about since we have two thruster
one for each eye where we're using the
intersection of those two for us so we
want things to be seen in both the left
eye and the right eye which makes sense
for a lot of tasks especially ones that
need start yes okay our reason why it
matters what angle an operator is
looking at something from like
highlights wishes is calm okay there's
nuts couple of things one is that this
is not so much an AR reason the angle
that you're looking at something from
may need to be a particular angle for a
particular task so in other words I'm
looking at a piece of equipment to fight
and there's some way in which I need to
see if it's aligned properly and the
right way to see that is to look at it
from particular angle
then simply highlighting the piece of
equipment isn't enough because now I
know you're looking at it that you're
not looking at it from the right
position in the right orientation okay
so make sense if I was trying to show
you how to use let's say a rifle right
you have to sight along it in a
particular way if I show you the two
sights
there's one over here and one over there
right and I say you need to look at
these I mean I could look at them like
this I could look at them like that but
I need to really line them up like this
and I need to be in the particular range
of positions and orientations to do that
because there's a relationship between
two things I need to see which I can't
see from your arbitrary position even
though both things I need to see would
be within my field of view okay
go through three holes to line up those
holes that that's an example of what's
called bore sighting right or looking
through a microscope right
yep yeah okay the thing I'm looking
through a microscope okay I show you the
objective of the microscope right I say
you need to look through this and you
could say I see it it's over here I see
it
get closer I see it but you need to be
like this right so there's an
orientation in position you need to be
in even though you can see that single
object from a whole wide range of
different positions and they give you
another example okay this is a fairly
loose constraint what I'm doing right
now I can I can be over here I can be
over here I can be looking at various
people these are more perfectly
reasonable things for me to do is giving
this talk okay on the other hand if I
were in the corner over here like this
unless there was a really good reason
for me doing that that's weird
okay I shouldn't be doing that during a
talk okay and so I could show you get in
terms of orientation the speaker should
stand over here
but if I were facing 180 degrees around
and not may be using that to point down
the screen with a laser pointer that's
not a reasonable position for someone to
be in during a talk like this make sense
yeah more question and have you thought
about their work
um again this is task-specific there's
some tasks in which the constraints are
loose I simply need to see whether this
bolt is in or not there's a wide range I
can do that I need to see whether the
bolt is in in a particular way I might
have a much tighter constraint on how I
have to look at it okay there may be
something that can be damaged
I have damage right in order to see them
damage because the damage might be very
very detailed low level fine damage
looking at it from a distance looks
great I might have to be really really
close to see that there's a problem okay
so let's move on from getting you there
to actually have you perform the task
and so in this work we're looking at how
we actually show you how to do something
yes I'm not your type yeah some studies
where the closer you get the brighter it
gets or the more stimulus you get anyway
this idea that the farther your way the
more stimulus you got this looks an
alternative thought you ever kind of
considered those two they sure know the
visualization which can show a person
yeah
oh you using ah you know where you're
far you know where you're often serves
you these things on the sides you know
you're doing all these things when
you're not there the thing is once you
get there you want to make sure you stay
there and if we kept stuff up visually
in your field that I think would detract
from the task so the idea is when you're
locked in everything is going to be fine
when you get out of range so to speak
then we're going to start doing things
to keep you from doing yeah sure I like
to do that so let me talk a little bit
about performing the task and so uh
we're interested in doing this in AR and
as you'll see also VR and so these are
just some examples of what's happening
so this is a view through a video
see-through display and so you're seeing
a task that involves assembling the top
and bottom parts of the one of the
combustion chambers for this particular
engine so this is the real physical
bottom over here this is a real physical
top and in this case our remote expert
has basically placed this virtual
representation of the top on top of the
bottom in the right orientation and part
of what we're going to be doing here to
show you how to do this after the remote
expert has done
this is by showing you these little
rubber band lines that are connecting
together appropriate port parts because
simply looking at what it looks like
when it's in place by itself in some
cases might not work all that well
because this top for example it's not
perfectly symmetric it has some little
thing sticking out in various parts that
mean it really needs to be in a
particular orientation not just
positions on top and there are some
views from which you might not even see
those things you don't know if you have
it in right and so this is just one way
of assisting a person is actually in the
middle of the task over here with making
sure that the right parts on each one of
them line up so in the work that we're
doing over here the local technician is
working in a our video see-through AR I
remotes me over here in the study that
we did is working in VR so all the
things that they're manipulating are
entirely virtual of course we could do
that virtual things added to a augmented
reality where they're seeing their
regular room for example but over here
we really wanted to concentrate just on
the virtual stuff and we have versions
of this but not ones that were part of
our study in which you can see through
the eyes of the local technician both
well we'll talk about that later
so what does this look like one of the
techniques we have we will call demo 3d
and here we have the summations
demonstrating the tasks to the tech in
VR now the tech has all of the physical
stuff in front of them we are using
mocap technology to track the position
and orientation of all of those physical
things and then we have copies of them
that are at the service of the remote
expert now the problem is it's a remote
expert then picked up one of those
virtual things and then started moving
it then since we don't have any robotic
so it would actually really do it at the
local task and if we did maybe wouldn't
you need the local technician and even
if we did there will be things for which
you still need to have a human being
they're more complicated things that can
go wrong because we don't do that if we
actually move them they would get out of
sync and so when the remote person goes
to pick something up but they really do
is they clone it
now they have a cloned copy they had to
control that they can have the local
person see without them moving of course
the copy that really is controlled by
the local technician so let me show you
what that looks like so here you're
seeing the sneezy they're picking up
that more transferring clone view
they're positioning it over there and
that's what's happening from the
standpoint of the remote person remember
they're able to talk with each other so
what does our local person see and so
you're going to see in a second of you
through or animated view through the
eyes of our local technician and what's
going to what's going to happen is our
remote expert is just finishing but not
quite done yet positioning that virtual
copy and so when I start the video
playing you're going to see this thing
moving around a little bit it's going to
change in transit in position it's also
going to rotate a little bit they're
still getting it in place
and the neat thing is that our local
person our real person our local person
can be physically moving our physical
copy in place while the remote person is
still moving the virtual copy and the
neat thing is that if you think about
gold standard well how would you what we
do want to compare this with you might
think what if I had that remote expert
not remote but standing right next to me
let's imagine they actually have another
copy of the top a physical copy and
they're going to put it in place and
show me how to do it if they do that and
I want to go and copy them they better
move it out of the way because you can't
have two things in the same place at the
same time physical things at least and
so here I would claim we have not done
this particular thing that I got to
claim yet that we could show that our
local person might be able to be more
efficient when there's not a physical
copy there that has to get removed but
there is a virtual copy okay even if you
had a person physically there but if
they were physically there and did all
the physical stuff physically then we
might not be as good so this is what it
looks like here we have our remote
person still moving it in place here's a
local person getting ready to match the
orientation I'm going to put it on over
there
and they match and we actually make the
copy control by the expert kind of seda
way to avoid the beating so to speak
visually of the remote experts copy and
the actual physical object itself so
obviously we have models of these things
that we use for what the remote person
sees and controls and that can be used
to properly obscure the remote virtual
copy relative to the actual physical
copy so let me give you another example
of another condition so I showed you one
of a set of they are conditions that we
did I'm not going to show you one in
which on the technician side excuse me
the experts side it's not a are and so
this is an example of something that's
very similar to a lot of systems that
are now being sold into industry and a
good comparison would be if you've ever
seen the hololens
video where there's the father advising
his daughter on doing plumbing and she's
got hololens on and he has a tablet and
he's scribbling on the tablet and she
then sees these scribbles in 3d in her
world that is really nice if you're
trying to name things and and show high
level things about the stuff in the
environment it's not good if the remote
person is trying to show how to
manipulate a tool for example and do
these things that are really 3d rather
than simply labeling stuff so this is
what our our sketch condition looks like
so here we have a person who's
scribbling on stuff we have a full 3d
model so we can send the scribbles which
are being drawn on the plane into the 3d
environment this is our textview that is
the head of the remote expert and you
can see those scribbles that are now
getting sent into and landing on the
different parts of the physical
environment which can be used of course
along with the voice communications
between them to show people what to do
so just to make a long story short over
here this is also within subject
experiment also counterbalanced by
technique and we basically were able to
show that the demo 3d from the
standpoint of the smee was significantly
faster for them to go and tell a person
to do
using the sketch to DT technique that I
just showed you okay and it turns out
this is actually a really difficult
experiment to run because what I wanted
to do is to have skilled non vested
interest
sMI's who would be essentially working
together with the less skilled
technician and in our work we basically
were doing this with recruited folks who
we did not have the opportunity to turn
into really really really good sneeze
and so our sneeze basically went through
a brief training course and what we'd
like to be able to do is to see what a
more skilled Smee would do and so when
we did the training the training was
done by people from our lab who knew how
to do this really well and we recorded
in fact results from them which were
essentially are really expert sneeze and
we also have results from our non vested
interest non-experts mays and to make
the non expert sneeze be more like a
Smee
we actually had as part of what they saw
their visualization would help them when
they were when the technician was doing
the right thing and help show them when
they were doing the right thing so we
highlight stuff for example indicate yes
that's right so then they could talk to
the technician and communicate that they
had done the right stuff so it's a
little bit like building the expertise
into the system itself to advise but
should be a innately expert person doing
stuff so I'm not actually properly
reflecting that what you say here is all
in the paper which I don't have a lot of
time to go into detail right now happy
to talk about later but we had basically
we we segregated the data from the the
experts who were really expert from the
experts who were being trained by our
real experts and who are actually
performing the tests as our so called
novice sneeze anyway so these are these
results work for yes
yes yeah poor the person yes was better
than drawing for the person doing the
doing or the drawing yeah they were good
evening if they weren't expert even they
were just the novice means they they
worked faster okay they got the message
across faster to the technician when
they were doing it in 3d rather than
when they were doing it by scribbling on
with that sketch 2d approach scribbling
on the tablet even though the scribbles
of course will really going into 3d and
landing on the right places in the
environment and this task as you can see
is not exactly one that requires a lot
of real delicate skill and complicated
trajectories in fact the trajectory
didn't really matter right all it really
counted was you put the top on top of
the bottom and you oriented it in the
right orientation I believe it would
even get better yes and I can give you a
goat 11/10 sort of wood but we did not
can get in the study so what I want to
do is to switch gears a little bit go
back to a single person and now we're
going to go to something that isn't
really a are at least in the study that
we did here we're going to be using
Google glass mano scopic very small
field of view okay and how many people
here have actually tried glass so I see
a majority of you have for those of you
who haven't you have probably seen
advertisements that's really not fair
not from Google you probably have seen
even papers in which people show you
what it looks like looking through glass
and a lot of them lie in terms of the
field of view the field of view of glass
if you hold your hand out like this
make a fist okay that is the size of the
field of view that you see roughly
around 10 degrees across okay and that's
not that your I think your phone may be
a little bit wider okay but if you
really did this and I was wearing glass
I would see obviously there's some
variation in human size right I'm not a
basketball player but I really would see
the image would be nicely framed by the
back of my hand and you'll sometimes you
will see papers
sadly in which they'll show the view of
the first wearing glass and it's
something around this big that's
appearing in their field of view and
unless they're way way back from
something that's supposed to be in front
of them you can't see that much the
field of view is not that big literally
is only this big so the problem with
this is in the task and I'm going to
show you over here this is one that
involves pure orientation okay so you
can see basically one of my students
holding this little object that's going
to be needs to be oriented you're now
seeing a view shot with a camera through
glass okay so that's a real image that's
not using the software that gets
provided for you to make images that
look like the received through glass you
can see the size of his hand you can see
the size of the task object itself and
if we were trying to actually annotate
by overlaying the task object with any
kind of visuals you couldn't do the
whole object this is not even all that
big you could do a little teeny tiny
piece of it so we wanted to not restrict
ourselves to having annotating just a
little tiny part of it and so what we
did actually is we did something a
little bit more classical that happens
in documentation we show you a picture
that shows the entire object obviously
not at the same size as the real world
obviously not tracking the thing in the
real world even though we are tracking
that object okay so we see it actually
move as you are being shown how to do
stuff so let me show you what this looks
like I'll show you a little video of
what it looks like being shot through
glass and then I'll talk about what it
is that we're trying to do so this is a
person manipulating this tracked object
using a particular visualization that's
designed to show them how to orient the
object from whatever it's starting
orientation is to a designated
destination orientation so let's see
what's happening over here in this
exploration we had this very very
specific task orienting okay to a
destination orientation you can think of
in the real world this would correspond
to something like what's the expiration
date on this product many times held
something in my hand put a lot of effort
in trying to figure out where the hell
it is okay and it differs from one thing
to another
what's the number that the university
stamped on this object to indicate that
they actually
it and they're going to stop by every
now and then to look at and they don't
remember where they put it you have to
go and you know figure out where they
actually put that little number okay so
there's many tasks like this in which
really nice if we could do it really
quickly and so in this work we came up
with a bunch of different ways to do
this we tried to think of all the ones
that would be relatively easy to think
of and we tried to see how could we
maybe combine and build on some of the
more obvious ones to make something that
would be as good as we can make it so
I'm going to show you basically just two
of these techniques okay the first one
is one I think that your typical geek is
going to come up with right
I want to orient from the current
orientation to an arbitrary distant
orientation how many rotations does that
take exactly one okay but it's going to
be about a very specific axis courtesy
of oiler we know that you can orient
something to any destination orientation
with one single rotation it's just that
the math gets to choose the axis and the
number of degrees that you go around it
so optimal rotation about one axis in
this particular visualization the axis
is being shown is this little barber
pole cylinder the direction and
magnitude of these little dynamic curved
arrows we're continuously updating what
you're seeing because we're tracking
this attract object we're doing the
little things like making sure the arrow
tip is always facing the user you know
clearly if we didn't do that right and
they are they are or could even be
blocked by the object if we did this in
a way in which we weren't careful that
stuff like that it turns out that doing
this is actually if you were a robot I
think this would work really well as a
human being you're not physically
constrained it's really hard to go about
that exact axis let alone this is not
even being seen in stereo alright you're
seeing the visualization in mono so this
can be a bit tricky okay and especially
as you get closer and closer the axis
you're getting a little bit off and
there's a new one you have to go about
and it turns out that we've put a lot of
effort into trying to do a really good
version of this and I think we came up
with a really good version it doesn't
work all that well so let me show you
what this looks like we are rotating
and the arrows are closing down and so
it goes green when you actually have
done it right as you're seeing over here
so this is one of the ones we came up
with this is actually the one that ended
up being the best and it was a result of
a lot of iterations and a lot of testing
and refining in this work we have
basically two dynamic control icons we
call them handles these little barber
pole like things that are sticking out
of the object over here and here okay
there are high visibility you don't
actually hold them because you're
holding the object in your hand okay
they're simply there virtually now the
idea is you need to get those handles
into these targets and targets are these
two little Tauruses okay two little
rings and those rings are always on a
horizontal line there are always exactly
where you're seeing always in front of
the user they're never going to be
blocked okay and then it turns out that
once we know and we constrain where
they're going to be that constrains the
legal places in which you can put the
handles that need to go and rotate into
them okay and we then can put the
handles in places in which they're they
themselves also are not going to be
blocked so your task as a user is you're
told you have to rotate the handles of
matching colors into their rings so the
red one needs to go into the red ring
the blue one needs to go into the blue
ring we have some little arrows that
show the rotational path that you can
follow there's many ways to do this or
some people who really like to do things
sequentially get the blue one into its
ring keep it there then get the red one
into its ring the more optimal thing to
do is to try to get them both into their
rings at the same time and that actually
is essentially accomplishes the same
thing as that single axis accomplishes
but you don't actually see the axis over
here you just got the handles that need
to go into the Rings so two things need
to meet up with each other and this is
what it looks like and then it turns a
green basically when you've done it
so in this user study again also within
subject we had a set of conditions and I
didn't go into detail about they
included Euler angles for example you
know what if the rotations were about a
set of three axes which were aligned
really nicely with the principal axes of
an object that looks literally like it
has principal axes maybe that would work
well so that was one of the other
conditions I didn't talk about in order
to be able to do this
another condition was animation so let
me show you an animation of it going to
its its end position or rather end
orientation right is that going to work
well we had an additional control which
is simply showing you attract view of
the thing you're holding in your hand
showing you the destination okay no
additional stuff I was like the leanness
we could come up with and that was a
fifth condition so in this work we had
an acceptance threshold of around eight
degrees which pragmatically ended up
being when people tried to task the
thing that we could really expect
everyone could be able to go and do once
we had a tighter constraint than that a
lot of people had difficulty really
matching it and maintaining him so the
end result or one of the end results yes
of what the learned result was post so
so you've gotten to might be able to
rotate something into Rizzo and
ultimately hopefully at least
fertilising to speak to describing he
was the person to have learned how to do
something right they have right now they
have a lot of a lot of artificial help
in getting the thing into the correct
orientation but have you studied what
happens actually reviewed then removed
the AR that's actually a very good
question we did not do that um there are
some casts in which there really is a
standard way of doing this or a standard
something that you'll encounter a lot in
which case that would be a good thing to
study there's others in which for every
single object it has a different
orientation it needs to be in you're
going to see a very large number of them
and I would claim that actually
having this assistance while you're
performing those tasks okay would be a
good way to do this as opposed to this
being kind of like trainer wheels that
later get removed but you're right there
are tasks in which you would this would
be how you would train someone but later
on you'd expect that then now know how
to actually do it and but we did not do
that that retrospective study so it
turned out that in this work and this
was among the things I we hypothesized
based on doing a lot of pilots and
really putting a lot of effort into
refining the different techniques a
handles was as we had actually
hypothesized significantly faster than
the other techniques the interesting
thing is that if you divide the the
actions that people do into two phases a
ballistic one and then kind of a
fine-tuning one and for us we made the
ballistic phase be up to the last 16
degrees doubled our threshold for
acceptability the handles and the
animate techniques end up being
essentially neck-and-neck as you can see
from the side over here there's no
difference really between those over
there what wins is the fine-tuning the
handles ends up being faster for
fine-tuning sufficiently so that it
actually ends up being significantly
faster across the board as opposed to
the animation approach that I didn't
show you what you see the object
animating to its destination and you're
basically are kind of copying what
you're seeing in place okay I realized
it and show that I'm happy to after the
talk is over go and show you at the
animation for ima looks like so to
finish up let me talk about one more
thing that I wanted to mention and
that's what I've shown you a lot of
things in which the idea is using AR or
in the case of these me actually using
VR to accomplish tasks much delay in a
great believer in AR and especially in
headward display based a are I don't
think that once we have the really good
headward displays that we'd like to have
on an everyday basis that every other
display is going to go away okay
technology really once it gets a toehold
it likes to stake stick around
and there are many things that are make
for the much better head worn displays
that will make for a much better and
less expensive large flat panel displays
and paint the will literally be a
display and carpets and walls it will be
displays I don't think they're going to
completely go away
so one thing that we are interested in
is what we call hybrid user interfaces
where we combine together different
kinds of displays and devices to try to
take advantage of their pluses and
minuses so this is just one still from a
particular piece of work we did in which
you're looking at a first generation
Microsoft Surface back when that name
referred to a rear projected tabletop
display in this case it's showing big
maps over here and these guys are
buildings courtesy of Microsoft these
are 3d models of buildings in downtown
New York and the cool thing is that this
is the bezel of the surface over here
these buildings clearly go beyond the
bezel and the way they do that is
because we're actually looking through
one eye in this case of a video
see-through display and we're tracked so
that the head is tracked in the same
environment as the surface itself so as
you're going to move around you'll see
these buildings actually being on top of
their footprints that are being
displayed on the surface and that means
that a person can walk into the
environment who's not wearing a head
were in display because much so I
believe in this stuff there are always
will be people who don't believe in it
and we want them not to see a bunch of
people you know moving around wearing
headward displays sharing a joke so to
speak we want them to participate also
so in this case if you walk in and you
see people who they see this you'll see
the actual tabletop and you can walk up
and say oh yeah tell me more about this
building over here and you can point at
it in fact it's a nice multi-touch
display and at least at the moment all
the things we can do with sensors that
are had worn trying to track delicate
finger things they don't work as well as
we'd like them to work and as they get
better and better they might not ever
work as well as that tabletop might
touch be touch sensitive to determine
the difference between what I'm doing
right now and what I'm doing right now
in which you know I can feel the change
in pressure but you know it's going to
take an awful
good set of sensors to determine exactly
what's happening anyway um so this is
one domain I'm going to show you one
from a different domain yes they are
plastic and I like to block the safe
behind it on you like and this is what's
called video see-through okay so we
combined you together
cameraman BRE okay this is a it's think
about a VR display but it has built into
it a pair of cameras and so the view
that I showed you that para frustum
before that was using a particular
display hm a one that Canon makes which
is insanely $2000 headwear display not
designed for regular consumers right
there was a very nice example of a video
see-through display with the cameras had
their optics folded so it was not as if
they were really over here but they're
really kind of like where your eyes are
okay so this is another video seater
display and consequently all the
combining of the real world seen by
cameras and of the virtual stuff created
in computers is done in the computer and
can be done in a way in which you can
block completely as opposed to with a
semi-transparent view the real world
stuff because it's just compositing
stuff and graphics okay so let me show
you one more view this is something we
did last year on student PR mlo working
with my group from a Polytechnique and
what you're going to see is a
combination of a perceptive pixel
display the forerunner of surface hub
it's down on the tabletop over here very
nice really sensitive multi-touch
display microsoft hololens which we're
looking through an elite motion
controller which you will make an
occasional appearance when you see down
somewhere around over here on the bezel
as the camera moves okay and that's
being used to do multi hand stuff now
full disclosure which people often don't
make when they show you stuff shot
through hololens Microsoft makes it very
easy for you to go in the produce video
that is the combination of the camera
that's in hololens with the virtual
stuff with a wider field of view than
how
really has and with the ability to have
the virtual stuff completely block as I
just showed you before the real stuff
that's not really what you see when you
look through hololens
but it's just so easy to make it that
way and if i did it the right way
everyone would wonder why videos look so
bad okay so I I relented so what you're
going to see here is a music exploration
example we're essentially putting this
all together with Spotify so we can look
at a bunch of artists and then see some
information about the album's they've
created in place and stuff so this is
what it looks like and there is audio
over here someone could make the audio
play so I guess you don't want to turn
the audio on and so here we're selecting
okay thank you
there were selecting things or seeing
those alters also for all hololens and
now the two hands were doing some leap
motion controller stuff so we have two
handed gestures we're looking in these
little shafts of light at artists albums
and then we can reach in and grab hold
to one of them grab it rotated
selected again back to halal and a song
and then we talked to Spotify and then
it starts playing some Dethklok so the
point over there is that this
combination of different planes okay I
think can make for really nice
interfaces where we don't ignore the
fact that just because I'm wearing a
head word display there's really cool
stuff in the environment which will only
get better and better you know higher
and higher resolution as it's already
happening lower and lower prices bigger
and bigger displays denser and denser
pixels so to wrap up I talked about a
are for skilled tasks I gave you some
examples of some of the stuff that we've
done in my lab and what I'd like to do
is to end by basically thanking the many
colleagues that have participated in
this and the funding agencies that made
it possible for us to do the work and at
this point I hope have a little time
left for questions thank you I've been
in that like you know place angel oil
over the phone oh my gosh you're breakin
a lot of times busy and it seems like
that that is that look at you showed
where there was like the multicolored
strings attaching my first words I think
looks really beautiful but I feel like
in all these directions that I have had
the least useful thing is when the
expert says something like move your
head 30 degrees and then shift your
shoulders right and then it's like does
that kind of direction is not a great
way to motivate a person to look at the
eye I agree in part because you have to
know what it means to move your head
that amount
so I would claim that you really need to
be over here to do something which could
be another example is I'm about to do
something over there in which one I
loosen this thing up every now and then
a bunch of hot oil is going to shoot out
okay you don't want to be standing or I
can see it perfectly right Ram so I
really need to be over there right yes
the time is worth it
okay so hot oil is going to shoot out
the direction that you make sense here
and then I'm motivated sometimes the
right way okay so the exact motivating
words and why you want to do it not just
because it's the better way to do it I
focus a certain type you know that's
something that till you make sense in
sometimes not in others the words are
not things that we are trying to control
over here and I've done stuff in the
past in which things like do it slowly
do it quickly have been things where
we've had systems that have generated
both words in conjunction with graphics
we did not try to do in graphics we
didn't try to come up with a way of
showing you slow we relied on words
because you're familiar with words right
like danger don't stand where you're
standing right now you might get hit
with hot whatever right but there really
are places where you might need to be
that are safe and so how is the person
going to tell you now they've motivated
there's some places where you're going
to get shot with oil bitten by this
particular very fast-moving animal you
know right how do I then tell you where
it is safe so if I simply told you that
some hot oil will spill out you might
say from where and it's one thing if
it's going to spray out right exactly
like this but it might spray out in a
more interesting pattern and if I
actually knew in advance that there were
safe places I think it would be good
you're right you can do the negative I
can show you the unsafe stuff and you
can see that you're in it or it could
also show you the safe stuff but it's
not just safe there's some places where
in order to be able to really understand
it you really need to be even though you
might not realize you'll need to be
there in a particular position and
orientation because there might be
something that you need to look at which
hasn't made itself known yet okay so
maybe it's something is going to move
the task isn't static
so they will move and you want to be in
the right view Incas ition and
orientation to see it before it happens
yes so I was really interested in the
user key that you describe where you had
to teach yourself your SME before they
were actually able to complete your task
you have any insight into why just not
not have enough to meet and teach
everything through they are okay on that
indeed the earliest stuff that we did
was automatically generate instructions
to perform tasks and then present those
instructions in earlier work I did
through conventional 2d displays in the
later stuff through AR because there are
certain things are a lot easier to do an
error like just highlight something if I
want to point out which one it is okay
but the problem is that if the world
worked exactly the way that we thought
it was going to work all the time we may
be able to do that but sometimes stuff
happens right if you're working with a
piece of equipment the instruction
manual tells you how to fix it maybe if
it's not been run over by something and
badly dinged and damaged and hurt in
ways in which you really need the expert
to help you and so in yes yes that would
be bad luck my SME eventually when you
send a person out in the field you're
not assuming that they're going to be
constant hand-holding so the idea is
there's many things they should be able
to do on their own and their own can
include with assistance or some kind of
documentation has been pre-created but
sometimes things happen and you you just
don't understand it and that's when you
get that remote expert to help you so
that's three problem solving this would
be if yes you're right again there's
many cases or if you don't need that
expert the expertise is something that
you've learned yourself for certain
kinds of tasks or has been built into
the documentation but we all know that
there are some cases in which you know
all the documentation doesn't seem to
help and it really helps to have someone
who actually know
more help us sadly now more and more
you'll seeing especially with online a
fake US companies being less and less
willing to provide that good
documentation in advance and more and
more willing to let the riffraff
contribute to these FA 2's or the same
question gets asked 37 different ways
and answered in many more different ways
many of which are wrong right so if you
really know what's going on you look at
the answer and you go people are
following this so yeah you're right you
we like not to have to have the remote
expert but sometimes they're needed so
the hot time we have for today well I
think I'll be sticking around
yeah well continue get your questions
answered see one person
you